اعلن قائد الكتيبه
7107 من قوات الاحتياط الاسرائيليه سحبها
من قطاع غزه بعد اشهر من المشاركه في
القتال هناك يتزامن ذلك مع ما تداولته
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن استعداد الجيش
لتقليل عدد قواته في شمال قطاع غزه وكان
وزير الدفاع يوف جلنت اعلن قبل نحو
اسبوعين عن انتهاء العمليات العسكريه
الكبرى في شمال
القطاع معنا الان من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس هل اتضحت اسباب
وحيثيات سحب هذه الكتيبه كتيبه الاحتياط
من قطاع
غزه هو واضح ان سحب هذه الكتيبه ياتي في
اطار اعاده الانتشار او اعاده التموضع
للقوات الاسرائيليه في منطقه شمال قطاع
غزه بناء على اعلان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي واف غلان قبل نحو اسبوعين عن
انتهاء المعارك ال الكبرى في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه وياتي ايضا بعد سحب
الفرقه 36 وسحب اعداد كبيره ايضا من جنود
الاحتياط الذين عملوا ضمن الفرق والكتائب
العسكريه في المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه
هذه كتيبه من كتائب وحدات المدرعات
والهندسه التي نشطت في اعمال التدمير
وايضا اعمال التي كانت تمهد الطريق امام
القوات البريه في الايام الاولى للعمليات
العسكريه الهجوم البري الذي بدا في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وكان مهمتها
تدمير المناطق التي تتوغل فيها القوات
الاسرائيليه وايضا نشطت في اطار عمليات
البحث عن الانفاق الهجوميه والبحث عن
معاقل حركه حماس في المنطقه الشماليه
لقطاع غزه وهي مؤلفه من جنود في الاحتياط
هي اصلا كتيبه احتياط وليست من كتائب
الهندسه ال الالزاميه اي وبالتالي ت تم
سحبها في اطار انتهاء العمليات العسكريه
الكبرى في تلك المناطق وهي تاتي ايضا في
فيما تقول وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ازدهار
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يستعد في مقبل
الايام القادمه ايضا
لتقليل اعداد قواته ووجوده العسكري في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه بناء على
القرار الذي كان اعلنه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلاند في هذا الخصوص دا عن
ذلك هنالك ايه لواء اخر يقوم حاليا في
مهمه تقطيع اوصال قطاع غزه بين المناطق
الشماليه والوسطى والجنوبيه وهذا اللواء
يتمركز تحديدا في المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه
غزه عند منطقه جحر الديك او عند شارع رقم
10 هذا الشارع العرضي الممتد من منطقه
غلاف غزه وحتى ساحل المتوسط وهدف هذا
اللواء هو قطع الطريق امام الفلسطينيين
الذين يرغب بالعوده من المناطق الجنوبيه
الى المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وهذا
اللواء مهمته الاساسيه منع الفلسطينيين من
العوده الى ديارهم وما تبقى من منازلهم
لان اسرائيل تريد ان تستغل ذلك كورقه ضغط
وورقه مساومه في اطار المفاوضات حول اتمام
صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى فيما زخم
المعارك ما زال على اشده في المناطق
الجنوبيه للقطاع ازدهار شكرا جزيلا لك من
تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كر ah